hey guys it is the final day of e3 and
the last day you'll see our faces for a
week but we've loved making you all this
content throughout III so we hope you've
enjoyed it too and there's still plenty
more to come next week so make sure
you're subscribed so you don't miss any
of the stuff we have lined up but for
now here's today's roundup the big game
of e3 this year is super mario odyssey
and today nintendo confirmed that it
also supports a local co-op on today's
Nintendo treehouse co-op was officially
shown off with one player controlling
Mario in the other Cappy Cappy is the
magic hat that lets Mario assume the
control of odyssey's inhabitants while
one player runs around as mario the
other can fly around is Cappy to protect
them and help complete puzzles the
controls for the player playing is Cappy
a much simpler and Nintendo intends for
this feature to help introduce newcomers
to video games in general super mario
odyssey will release for Nintendo's
switch on October 27th when Bungie
revealed destiny today also said that
matchmaking is coming to the game for
high-level content like raids in the
form of guided games although it looks
like there are some limitations speaking
on Kotaku z3 podcast Game Director Luke
Smith confirmed that guided games will
be limited to Normal difficulty
activities heroic level raids and
nightfall strikes will still require
players to have their own groups to play
with Smith said I don't know exactly how
the challenge mode layers are going to
work with guided games but the normal
tier activities will be guided games and
the heroics will be find your own in
other destiny 2 news the game's
exclusive playstation content will
arrive on PC and Xbox one next year
according to a tweet from game director
Luke Smith when the content was
announced activision stated the
exclusivity would last until at least
fall 2018 that means you can probably
expect it on Xbox one and PC sometime
between September and December 2018 the
exclusive content includes the sniper
rifle borealis armor a ship crucible map
retribution and the lake of shadow
strike finally that story we told you
about yesterday about Sony not wanting
to get in on cross play with Minecraft
it's making a little more
since today does that if you want to get
in on cross play on switch you're going
to need an Xbox Live login wait what
yeah
the latest Minecraft update will unify
it across all platforms except for Sony
devices that means minecraft players on
switch will be able to play with those
on Xbox one or PC but it also means
Nintendo switch owners will have to log
in to Xbox Live to play the game online
Xbox boss Phil Spencer explained we use
Xbox Live as the way to make sure we
know who our players are controls around
parental controls and other things that
we put into our platform are there and
as you're buying things in Minecraft you
want to make sure you have them
available on other platforms so we have
to know who you are
if you have a realm that you've created
on the PC and you want to get it onto
the switch we have to have an identity
system and we just use Xbox Live he
added that there is unlikely to be
achievements because Nintendo doesn't
have them and that's games what news for
today and for the next week but in our
stead make sure you grab the game spot
now app so you can get the top 10 news
stories of the day delivered right to
your phone we really hope you've enjoyed
our coverage of e3 do let us know what
you thought of today's show and the
entire show down in that comment section
and we will see you again soon
we're going to Disneyland yeah
[Music]